Rogue planets are planets,
the travel through the universe alone.
They inhabit the dark and fast space between the stars drifting alone through
eternal darkness.
No light warms their surfaces and they're exposed to the freezing cold of outer
space.
They know no seasons,
no days,
and no nights,
which could give away the passing of time and yet rope candidates might carry
alien life to all corners of the galaxy.
How would that work and how does a planet become a rogue anyway?
Yeah,
there are several very different things that get called rogue planet.
For example,
sub brown dwarfs gas giants that form from collapsing gas clouds and are the
boring little brothers of brown dwarfs there a sort of failed star and will now
stop talking about them.
A far more interesting sort of rogue.
Our terrestrial planets similar to earth that got kicked out of their planetary
system.
Young star systems aren't dangerous places where Protel planets are battling for
the available mass guzzling up as much material as possible in this fight for
dominance.
They collide with each other or get dangerously close to each other's orbits.
If a very massive planet moves,
it's all big closer to the star.
It can kick smaller planets out of the system,
but just because of pen,
it has survived.
The growing pains of formation doesn't mean it's safe.
Planetary systems can be disrupted by fly buys from stars or black holes at any
point.
Up to half of all planets board could end up as rogues.
The scientists don't agree on the numbers,
but it's likely that at the very least,
there are billions of rogue planets in the Milky Way alone.
Most rogues,
we'll share the same depressing fate as their star becomes a smaller day.
By Day,
the planet's surface quickly cools down to minus 270 degrees Celsius.
If they have oceans,
they'll freeze and become as hard as bedrock.
Their atmospheres will sink down to the surface and eventually freeze too.
But weirdly enough,
some of these frozen dark deserts could harbor life
to understand how,
let's imagine a planet similar to Earth in the same order of magnitude in terms
of mass and composition.
If we put it into deep space,
how good it still support life.
As far as we understand the nature of life.
There is one indispensable ingredient.
It needs liquid water.
Water is important because it mixes things both matter and energy,
which lets interesting chemistry happen like life.
So our planet needs enough energy to keep at least a part of our oceans warm
enough to sustain liquid water.
Annoyingly about 99.97% of Earth's energy budget comes from the sun.
So our imaginary Rogan needs to work with the 0.03% of energy it has left,
which almost exclusively comes from it's hot center.
Earths in a core is a giant metal ball about as hot as the surface of the sun
that surrounded by the outer core made up of liquid metals that are very,
very slowly solidifying,
releasing a lot of heat in the process.
As long as this process is ongoing,
our planet will be geologically active with solid and liquid material moving
around and transporting energy to the surface where it can be harnessed as
geothermal energy while the hot core of every penny.
It will cool off.
Eventually.
This process takes billions of years,
enough time for life to come into existence and thrive.
There's even one scenario that could allow an earthlink panic to have oceans
that are not frozen over.
If the planet had an extremely dense and high pressure hydrogen atmosphere,
the gas would not freeze and could travel enough of the heat trying to escape
the panties to enable oceans that extend all the way to the surface.
And there's another possible way to stay warm moods.
If a rope can,
it brings a moon or more along with them or large enough moon could inject
additional energy into the system via tidal forces.
These forces stretch and squeeze the panicked a little bit every day like
kneading dough,
keeping it warm.
But the most likely scenario for a rogue bearing life is one with sub place.
She'll oceans under a kilometer thick layer of mostly water ice.
These are not completely absurd since we already have a few of them in the soda
system.
So how could life sustain itself at the bottom of a completely dark cold ocean
on earth?
Deep down in our oceans in complete darkness,
in volcanically active areas that are hydrothermal vents called black smokers.
They spew out a cloud of black material and hot water,
providing a constant flow of minerals from Earth's mantle bacteria feed on the
minerals and produce organic materials,
which attracts crustaceans by valves,
snails,
fish,
octopus and tube worms up to two meters long.
Not only our hydrothermal vents home to an incredibly diverse group of living
beings,
but also a contender for the place where life could have begun on earth billions
of years ago in the dark ocean of a rogue planet.
Similar vents or volcanic activity could be the starting point and basis for
complex ecosystems.
We can only imagine right now one upside and ecosystem in a row pan it ocean has
is that the environment is extremely stable.
The thick ice,
she protects it from all sorts of extinction events and as long as the energy
from the core keeps on coming,
things stay pretty much the same.
The most likely forms of life are bacteria and other microorganisms,
but given enough time,
more complex alien animals could feed on the smaller beings and thrive.
It's not impossible that intelligent life could emerge in such an environment.
If it did,
it would find itself in a pretty weird world,
constricted by an wall of rock,
hard ice at the top and bedrock at the bottom without any plants to store star
energy.
There would be no wood oil or coal.
Even if there were,
it's not like you discover fire at the bottom of an ocean.
Without this energy.
Metals may never be forged into useful.
Things are intelligent.
Alien friends might never break through the ice.
They might never realize that there is such a thing as outside and assumed that
their small world is all there is.
Millions of generations might live and die in these dark oceans.
Ignorant of the unbelievably big universe of Buffy ice until the core of that
planet calls off and all life finishes as the oceans completely freeze the
remnants of cultures and ecosystems will be trapped in an icy grave forever.
If you think about it,
it might be better not to be aware of all that,
but the concept is disturbing and exciting.
The universe might be teeming with life trapped on pallets that are basically
impossible to leave.
Worlds like this could frequently pass the soda system without us even knowing
maybe one day in the far future humans will set foot on one of these frozen
worlds and try to say hello.
Okay,
so we love gluey future scenarios but let's go back to the present for a
different kind of surprise.
Many of you want to know how we make our videos.
So we made a video about that cause cause zones teamed up with skill share,
a favorite online learning community for creators to make a three part series of
classes where you can learn how unique animation style with scenes from our
videos,
but we're not the only ones telling you our tips and tricks there.
A skillshare premium membership gives you unlimited access to more than 25,000
clauses in all kinds of skills like writing,
design and animation from experts who know their stuff.
The premium membership is as low as $10 a month,
but as a treat,
the first 1000 people to use the link in the description,
we'll get their first two months for free.
If you've always wanted to see how we animate our videos and learn to do it
yourself,
this is your chance.